i want to pull up this story here we
have from wusa9
group to hold vigil outside supreme
court justice samuel
alito's home in response to potential
roe v wade overturn the group plans to
host a vigil near leader's home starting
at 7 30 p.m blah blah blah a vigil
oh a vigil so they already went to
kavanaugh's house which is illegal and
now they're going to alito's house which
is illegal but don't worry it's a vigil
what a protest a vigil so the law says
the the us code
you cannot parade or pick it in front of
a judge's house i'm simplifying it
but
i think it makes sense the court
precedent or the legal precedent is that
due process and justice
supersedes your right to free speech
because without those process processes
you can't have free speech
so in this instance people should not be
going to the homes of these justices but
anyone want to take a bet as to when or
if any of these people will get charged
with any kind of crime
checking your head already everybody
well let me tell you if any of them do
get uh if any of them do get charged
we're gonna see politicians tweeting out
the link to the gofundme to get them
bailed out yeah so this is a vigil the
definition is uh the act of keeping
awake at times when sleep is customary
so they're just going to go sit and stay
awake all night outside his house no
they're screaming if they're screaming
then it's it's a protest right right
it's it's semantic games manipulation
exactly
well we already know that jen saki has
no negative words to say about these
protesters she's like well people
sometimes feel very passionate
oh yeah they felt passionate on january
6 and you have a very different view of
that well i mean
there's a january 6 is different from
showing up someone's house but chung
with someone's house is overt worse in
some ways worse in some ways in many
ways actually but genseki did walk this
back she came out and she was like she
tweeted it's probably not even her it's
like some intern tweeting like sent out
a message and she was just like violence
can never be tolerated and people should
feel safe it's like i missed the part
gen where you included don't go to the
homes of these justices
which they're doing
so i think uh
i was i was talking about this earlier
a lot of people say it's worse now than
it's ever been but then people like to
point out the assassination attempts of
the past and the weather underground you
know the weathermen and the bombings and
stuff and death i think back then we had
acute spikes of of uh political
extremism and today we have a low
consistent rumbling of extremism which
is worse it's death by a thousand cuts
the way i explain it is if we in the
past had an assassination attempt that
would be like someone taking a pic
pickaxe to the whole of your ship boom
they punch a hole in it the water's
spraying through and you're like quick
we better patch this hole up and
everyone panics and you rush and you
patch the hole up today
it's a thousand small holes and you
can't patch them up fast enough it is
death by a thousand cuts so this low
level rumbling that is affecting every
level of government that's consistent i
mean i'll put it this way i've been
saying for how long tensions are
escalating potential civil war or strife
or whatever some kind of some kind of
hyper polarization then geographic
polarization and then we get a story
about the overturning of roe v wade when
i even said before the story came out
that i think abortion could be a
catalyst for another civil war and not
just me stephen marsh said it he's the
guy who wrote the book the next civil
war and now sure enough
it drops they're going to overturn it
they're holding firm with the latest
leaks people are already starting to
protest in front of justice's homes
law students are defying the idea of the
sanctity of the court
how could we
how are we going to pull this together
and get past this in any meaningful way
it's really hard to re-establish
deterrence once it's been lost right and
that deals like in the international
arena with military strategy
whether it's law enforcement or just
basic norms and ethics once one side you
know it's like that it's like that
driver that everybody hates who just
kind of realizes that i can actually
just cut everybody off and i can just
cut across traffic and make turns as
long as i don't get caught by i might be
inconveniencing everybody else but i'm
going to get to where i want to go
quicker than anybody else
and he realizes maybe on some level that
if everybody started doing that then
nobody's getting anywhere that they're
trying to go but he knows that the good
faith of those other people means that
they're not going to do it so he can get
away with it he gets there and once you
have kind of allowed that to metastasize
and become normal for
certain people or even you know can it
can spread i mean the real frightening
thing that people have been talking
about for a long time
is that what happens when the right
starts acting this way now they have a
you know there are reasons that they
wouldn't ideologically maybe there are
also obviously we see january 6 there
are law enforcement reasons why they
wouldn't do it they get treated very
differently but if they just decided to
ignore that stuff and they started
responding to things violently and they
started showing up to judges homes they
didn't like at that point
you've lost control of you and the only
way to regain control is to probably use
a pretty extraordinary amount of force
because you have a bunch of people who
don't think that you're going to do it
it would i don't think i don't think
that could solve it if
the the federal government or law
enforcement cracks down
on the left and the right it would just
exacerbate the hyperpolarization so you
have january 6. it's bad i mean people
should not have rioted the people who
mindlessly trespassed when the cops
opened the door for them should
shouldn't have in my opinion been
charged because these are the magamimas
already one guy got his his charges
dropped because the judge was like the
cops let you in what am i supposed to do
about that there's gonna be a lot more
like that but there are a lot of violent
people who should be charged so so
that's bad
you see people who are facing solitary
confinement people who have been locked
up for over a year for this
then you look at the left you had the
insurrection on january 20th 2017 where
hundreds of people were running through
the streets smashing things starting
fires torched a limousine
these people not only were had their
charges dropped the city was forced to
pay out to them in a lawsuit now you can
talk a lot of this to the fact that
they've been organized the left has
organizational power and collectivist
power they've been dealing with for a
long time
but when you see
the fbi agents going to bubba wallace's
i think it was this is his name right
the nascar guy over a garage poll wrote
yeah but but but then you see these
people show up to judges homes and
there's no law enforcement action or the
people who who uh you know were throwing
firebombs at federal buildings some of
which have been charged mind you but man
charged but many who haven't it is
lopsided the right gets angry and says
we have no justice if the right starts
acting out which they did on january 6
and then the boot comes down on them
which it did
you can you what you have done is you
have struck through the heart confidence
in the american system if there is no
justice for me then what's the point of
participation
yeah well and so you mentioned that
there were certain individuals there who
basically had the doors open for them by
the police they walked through i think a
large section of the country knows that
at this point they also know that there
were people who didn't engage in any
kind of
misconduct of any sort who were put on
trial so for example we had marjorie
taylor green as a fantastic example who
was i believe they were trying to smear
her as an insurrectionist and actually
get her charged so that she could not
run in her state so the idea is to get
people who would otherwise protest
peacefully or be involved in you know
trying to
bring about civic change to just stay
home so long as they have a certain
perspective and of course that
perspective is a conservative one i want
to bring up this uh op ed from over at
timcast.com from josie the redhead
libertarian she writes
if you're pro-abortion after viability
and ever wondered if you would have been
an abolitionist i have some bad news for
you
she makes an interesting point about uh
roe v wade and and casey
and that basically row actually did
entertain the conversation around
viability quote as is from the from
robbie wade as we have intimated above
it is reasonable and appropriate for a
state to decide that at some point in
time potential human life becomes
significantly involved the woman's
privacy is no longer soul and any right
of privacy she possesses must be
measured accordingly
and according to row the 14th right to
privacy clause is not absolute regarding
pregnancy although the results are
divided most of these courts have agreed
the right of privacy however based is
broad enough to cover the abortion
decision that the right nonetheless is
not absolute and is subject to some
limitations and that at some point the
state's interests as to protection of
health medical standards and prenatal
life become dominant we agree with this
rep with this approach josie writes so
once again according to roe we have a
clear understanding that a baby is a
baby at viability and it's fair for
states to regulate proposed termination
if they so choose
we also have a clear understanding
thanks to roe that a mother's personhood
may not be absolute at that point in
some states and it's fair for states to
regulate proposed termination of a baby
if they so choose
roe had limited abortion in the first
trimester but thanks to planned
parenthood v casey that part of roe was
overturned so states can already do what
they want barring absolute bans of the
practice
emotional arguments aside this is an
extreme unpopular and highly unlikely
outcome no matter how many legislator
legislators co-sponsor the bill
in terms of property rights historically
people in some states rejected the idea
that they did not have ownership over
another human even when the laws in
other states said yes this person is a
human here when they believed a separate
human belong to them that this separate
human was less than human and that they
could do with that human as they pleased
but uh by no hyperbole that was slavery
here's my here's my thoughts on this we
mentioned last week
almost as far almost every instance i
can think of when there has been an
attempt to expand personhood
constitutional rights to a group of
people that is ultimately played out and
we've seen that actually with the trans
argument states across the country are
now entertaining uh gender identity as a
protected class even at the federal
level in many ways they're doing it so
this happens
why would babies be the one exception to
this tendency throughout history in
which case it seems
that the only likely outcome is going to
be abortion becoming banned based on
historical trends
i mean it's it's
gender as a protected class is a
slippery slope because you can if
someone's able to choose their gender at
will and then gain a protection of some
sort legally that's complete insanity
so i don't know what's happening i think
if we're talking about viability baby
viability and as viability is getting
less and less it's getting shorter and
shorter like now a five-month-old baby
can be born into an incubator and live
there for three months and then as it
matures but if the
i don't know if that's really considered
viability because if the plug comes out
then the baby dies and like
well it's an interesting question it's
um if the baby can survive independent
of a mother i mean there are people who
their kidneys fail and they need
dialysis but they're still considered
viable human beings so the issue is as
technology progresses viability will
extend all the way to day one i'd
imagine eventually in fact day zero
we'll probably be able to we've already
grown i think sheep in bags
so certainly the same can be done for
humans it's just an ethical question of
you know not we should not do that
so i think that's that's that's like a
step of like they might start harvesting
women's eggs in ovulation because they
are viable
that's crazy psycho you can't do that
well no there's a yeah there's a
difference between an egg and a zygote
like they cannot allow it to well the
difference is it's unfertilized but
doesn't mean once the sperm enters and
you have like a completely unique set of
human dna i don't think that there's
anyone who argues the only people who
argue that an egg cell is equivalent to
a zygote or pro-choicers who are trying
to straw man pro-lifers what about like
birth birth control why is the church so
against birth control uh because the
purpose of human sexuality is unity and
procreation and birth control perverts
one of those purposes it's not because
there is an act of murder which occurs
which is the
uh ins which is what we see with
abortion it's for very different reasons
so when we talk about viability i'm just
concerned about the technological aspect
of the viability i get it like if the
mom's not around the baby's gonna die
until it's like 11. you know maybe a
child can't take care of itself but if
talking about breathing machine that's a
different story but i think i think this
question of viability plays exactly into
what i was thinking last week with the
inevitability of abortion being banned
if technology progresses to the point
where a baby is viable the moment of
conception through an artificial womb
and there's a question in the in
actually in row about at what point
viability makes this life form a person
under the constitution and worthy of
protection if their initial assessment
was well by the second trimester you've
got you've got a baby with a heartbeat
and a brain and all that stuff so it's
its rights are now in play here
well then if the baby is viable from day
zero the moment of conception then why
would we ever allow abortion at that
point one time once technology gets to
that point it seems like i'll put it
this way the question of trans rights
only exists because of the invention the
iso the isolation of hormones before we
actually knew what hormones were and how
to get them there there were people who
identified as trans but there was no
hormone replacement therapy
now that we have that we have a question
constitutionally about how far this can
go and ultimately we're seeing states
starting to enact gender identity
protections
technology is going to do the same thing
for human life in terms of abortion i
think the end result is abortion gets
banned i've always fantasized about some
future scenario where they actually
isolate the gay gene the gene that makes
you a homosexual and then conservatives
start aborting all their gay babies and
then you have all the people on the left
actually coming out and protesting
against abortion and trying to ban it
that would be interesting i i honestly i
don't think conservatives would do that
i don't either yeah i don't is there
there's not actually a gay gene i don't
think no i'm
this theory and you guys are welcome to
disagree with me but one of the reasons
that human infants are born and it's so
difficult is because their heads are
huge and the reason that they're born so
early is because unlike baby giraffes
and baby elephants we don't just get
squeezed out on the savanna and start
running immediately because we have huge
brains this is part of the reason why
you could potentially argue that a
three-year-old child is not viable
because if you leave a three-year-old
child to its own devices it will die in
relatively short order it will starve
it's unable to feed itself or whatever
or or raised by wolves oh yeah exactly i
mean that's possible it's happening
exactly no and start to start a city
called romero
i also viability is a very bizarre way
of determining when a person should get
rights for a number of reasons but i
think most importantly because
one of the entire like if not almost the
entire reason that we recognize rights
politically is to protect the weak from
the strong so the more vulnerable a
person is the more necessary it is to
extend rights to them so to look at
viability and say they're actually
particularly vulnerable at this point so
we're not going to extend
the right to life to them
is completely self-defeated it's a
luxurious way of looking at it in like
tribal society old war society the most
vulnerable will be killed off
immediately because they're going to
hold the tribe back and get it killed ex
their rights were not recognized but we
don't want to live in a society where
somebody is killed because they're quote
unquote holding us back or because they
require more resources or because they
can't produce as much and ian this is
not sparta no that's right
we just set it like a spartan tip
you know madness i i couldn't well you
can't do it aggressively because the
joke is it's not sparta yeah this is not
sparta we don't put our children the
baby would be born like put in the woods
yes for like a day and if it didn't
survive like it was weak i guess
viability maybe is can the baby breathe
on its own
after you suction out its lungs can it
just lay there and there are people
there are people with no lungs there are
people who have lung damage and they get
put on special machines so like for a
healthy baby not for a not for one with
a
but like a healthy fully formed
at what stage of its gestation can it
start to breathe on its own there there
are there are people who are born um
missing certain vital organs and we we
find ways for them to survive and live
but those are the excess i mean
specifically for like healthy term
babies that are five months or four
months i don't think that's i don't
think you can define viability basically
well if you have like a loved one on a
machine and they can't breathe you can
pull the plug and if you have a guy with
a pacemaker or you have someone with uh
with insulin shots like come on
that's not an argument there there are
diabetic people who have insulin pumps
bluetooth
with tubes going into their bellies
and that machine is keeping them well
they can make the choice for themselves
it's the people that can't make whatever
what about
babies and brain people that have brain
no brain basically they can't choose for
themselves so other people have to
decide are they going to pull the plug i
don't know people decide you're thinking
i just i don't think you can define
i don't think viability is a criteria
for rights or anything like that i just
don't see it well that's i mean you can
pull the plug on someone that's in in a
vegetable state you can pull the plug on
a diabetic
if they're unconscious maybe no no a
six-year-old doesn't want to get insulin
you've got to provide it to them and
make sure you're the one that's that's
murder if you if you if you don't give
your six-year-old it's not it's insulin
and it dies if you have if you have a
baby on a ventilator you shoot the
ventilator off that's murder if it can't
if it doesn't have brain access it can't
make that decision so someone else's
six-year-old can't make the decision
either well technically they can they
have brain activity i'm just talking
about people without brain activity or
like babies in the womb where you can't
communicate with there are people who
experiences loss of uh brain function
and go into comas for very long periods
of time and they recover so it's like
the if you unplug them you're killing
them and and the challenge morally is
that sometimes we're like is this person
going to recover and people have to make
a hard decision about whether we say
it's time or it's not and the scary
thing is sometimes after long periods of
time years people do recover so do you
want to be the person pulling the plug
but my point is it's legal to pull the
plug in those situations and when if
it's someone that's healthy it's not
legal to have them killed okay that's an
unborn child is healthy and they're
developing they're just not at a stage
of development where they can make
choices so that's a different scenario
so in in this in the environment if
they're taken out of the womb at four
and a half months they're not going to
be healthy but if if you removed them
from the womb yeah i mean they could be
they're perfectly healthy at that stage
of development but yeah but relative to
their environment but and that's also
part of why you can't remove them i mean
you can't remove someone from an
environment where they're perfectly
healthy and sit and say you know what
i'm not going to give you the treatment
that you need given the fact that i just
stripped you from the environment that's
good for you i think the legal argument
would then be oh you can remove them so
long as you replace 100 with what you've
taken from them right so if we get to
the point technologically where a baby
can at whatever stage be it one week two
weeks or even one day be placed in an
artificial womb i think the termination
of the baby becomes illegal outright now
abortion in some sense like the removing
of the baby from the woman i think
becomes overtly legal at all stages at
that point because then the baby will
always survive right i truly believe if
they do that one day one you can take it
out and put in a machine that it's gonna
lead to people harvesting eggs and
saying you cannot ovulate it is illegal
for you to obviously oh come on man
now that that's that's absurd i know it
it sounds absurd but
stuff like that well i mean yeah maybe
the ccp might do crazy stuff like if we
start legislating that they have
to the world and then like why not day
zero why not day negative one because
the point would be when life begins at
conception but those eggs are alive
they're just not human fertilizers
they're not it's living tissue it's it's
when when an egg is fertilized
when a man loves a woman yes life begins
a conception an egg is is is a component
of the creation of life but it is not
the life
well it's a it's a it's a piece of
living meat or whatever it is it's the
egg itself i don't know what's good
i think the question is there's no
potential there's no potential life so
that's what it is is potential life now
only when it meets with the sperm and
then it becomes it's
life so like i got eggs from the
chickens they sit on the shelf until
they rot and explode yeah there's
there's no potential there unless
they're fertilized oh i disagree and
even if they're fertilized they require
specific conditions but anyway
let's let's let's let's move on to i
think we'll just i mean what do you
think you've been listening well i think
this is
obviously an incredibly complex moral
question right which is why the i think
the conservative perspective on this is
not to seek a maximalist position trying
to ban abortion or drive it back to the
first day after fertilization
but to recognize the complexity of it
recognize that there are probably
irreconcilable views that people are
going to have
and allow alabama and new york to have
different abortion laws that they work
out through
the discourse and their democratic
processes you know it's i think it's
it's
going back to the idea of like
conservative the way conservatives look
at politics as something that is that we
engage in to make sure that we all wake
up tomorrow we're not killing each other
i think that's the in that sense the
conservative way of way of approaching
it i mean because we like if if the way
humans gave birth
was a woman got fertilized and then the
egg like popped out and then you put it
in a plastic bag in the fridge and then
it grew into a human like after that
that was just how humans you know
evolved say to uh
then we wouldn't allow abortion at all
you would have it there in the bag that
came out the first day and we'd be like
no you can't flush that thing down the
toilet we'll take it or whatever and but
you can't you can't do that to it
this question only becomes really
relevant because you're dealing with a
very real
rights claim you know a woman's right to
control what goes on with her body that
is a
however anybody feels about abortion you
have lots of people i think
libertarian types maybe who
are
anti-abortion but they're very like they
want to end the drug war because they
think that a person wants to put
something into their body than they
should be able to it's it's bodily
autonomy it's a real argument that
you know that that
conservatives i think have have more
recently done a better job of of dealing
with but it's something that you know it
does have to be dealt with i mean you're
you're talking about uh
you know
just basic basic rights when you're
talking about somebody's ability to
control what happens with their body
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you